you'll think of this IV I know that
you'd heard of thistle farms Allison but
had you ever heard of this alive I've
been drugs and alcohol free for about 22
years I've been I've been a different
program little bit yeah but it was it
was somebody of a different sort who
reached out to me so many years ago now
even in my position which was very
different but because I had money and I
was a star you people help they enable
you to get by and it wired what you said
it was the program I practice it's all
about as soon as you get it you got to
give it away you can't a kid can't hold
on to all these toys and every time you
seize new toy he goes why and he got a
drop one of those for it can give you
another one so what important that she
said and it it really resonated with me
is that you get it it doesn't happen
overnight it's a day-to-day thing you
get a reproof Rees every day but I said
that giving back which somebody gives
you this I see this happen right here
this is a miracle I see it in my
particular program I see well and also
that what you're saying though is you
are amazing Becca for providing this
opportunity for people and that person
is amazing for general I don't go and
hey there's a problem but at the same
time you have to be willing to receive
it you have to be willing to engage and
you you have to be able to change your
life somebody can't do that for you so
that's the amazing part as well and I'm
so so excited to meet you and so proud
of you graduate and say thank you
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going